Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
May 21st,
2000 and a what is it,
18 2018 what's going on?
How?
Why?
Yeah.
Um,
how you doing?
You doing good?
Oh,
that's good.
That's good.
Um,
now the gloomy,
gloomy,
rainy,
misty day out here in la.
It's been like freezing,
you know,
glow.
Um,
yeah,
that's the tail.
It's just all a,
I dunno,
it's like nine o'clock out here,
nine o'clock.
It feels like it's a fucking six in the morning over there.
This is one of these days.
I kind of,
it's a how I going to get anything done second.
It's all cloud.
This son man,
it's something in the sun makes you want to get up and do stuff,
man.
All of a sudden it's a little bit overcast and that your internal clock is like,
hey man,
well look,
maybe we should just like laid down and like to that tomorrow man.
How anybody gets anything done in Seattle is fucking beyond me or San Francisco
for that matter.
Even though I lucked out with all this great weather.
When I was up there.
But Jesus Christ,
you must just get used to it.
You know,
if you're successful in like Seattle,
you've gotta be able to be successful anywhere.
Right.
Um,
I was speaking to that shit.
I was watching this thing on the 90s,
right after my [inaudible] was watching.
Uh,
she's watching the royal wedding.
I came back from San Francisco,
by the way,
thank you to everybody who,
uh,
came out.
That was an incredible week.
I had such a great time up there and,
uh,
I drank too much.
So now I'm back back on the food and the booze wagon.
I'm on the elliptical,
turning it all around.
I'm on the road,
Billy booze bag at home.
Fucking father O'Malley.
Well,
that's probably not a good thing to say.
Huh?
Catholic priest.
Hoy.
He can't tie teachable.
Um,
what am I trying to say?
So I come back,
you know,
I'm all excited to see my wife and kid and I come home and,
uh,
she's watching that royal wedding,
which was literally the whole fucking wedding.
Oh my God.
I felt so bad for that.
The fucking guy,
whoever.
What is it,
Harry?
He can't just get married.
It's got to be all of that.
You know,
everybody all dressed up in these crazy hats and shit.
It was like the fucking Kentucky Derby met meets like medieval manner.
They was missing was Jim Carey's character in that cable guy,
movie doubt downtown bed going down.
When was they were there at that fucking,
you don't want a theme restaurant there?
Um,
what up?
I'm happy for balls at that they filed love for their together.
Jesus Christ.
So she watched the whole God damn thing and uh,
so she's upstairs.
So I was like,
okay,
I'm going to go on pack downstairs.
We've got a TV downstairs.
I go downstairs and uh,
and the processes,
me unpacking,
she came downstairs cause she wanted to hang out with me and,
and she turned on the fucking the wedding down there
and I believe I yelled into a thick bathrobe.
I would just like [inaudible]
why didn't you say,
I said,
it's great to be back with you in May.
So I walked in there and,
uh,
I just was like,
I know I'll just slowly walk out of the room and I got all the way out of the
room and closed the door to within two inches since she was like,
where are you going?
Psych,
I'm going to go upstairs.
She's like,
why I wanted to hang out with you.
It's like,
all right,
well,
I can't watch this.
She goes,
it's almost over.
So I went upstairs and,
you know,
I don't know.
I get her watching that,
that,
that would be like,
but that would,
that the royal wedding would be like me trying to get her to watch.
Um,
I dunno.
Some Hall of fame induction ceremony after she's been away for five days,
you know?
Um,
oh,
I had a hilarious thing after me.
I put on us in San Francisco,
right.
So I'm eating like an asshole.
I went to this Vietnamese restaurant.
I never eat Vietnamese food.
I don't know why.
I'm a creature of habit.
I will eat Sushi and Ali like Chinese food and I'll eat Indian food.
Oh,
I'll dance all around that continent.
But for some reason like Vietnamese food,
you know,
I'm like I don't know about that.
I Dunno.
Yeah.
Thai food I had a long time ago and I got food poisoning off it so I wouldn't,
I can't even for like 10 years.
And then also I always get the same fucking thing cause the,
the,
the menu is just overwhelming cause I don't know what anything is and I don't
want to make a mistake so I always get the,
uh,
what the fuck is it called?
I don't know.
Nia knows what it is.
And she goes,
you're going to get this thing again.
And every time I get Sushi get the exact same Sushi,
spicy,
yellow tail hand roll of something else.
Set up salmon,
avocado,
some edamame.
Me.
Right.
You get the same thing every time.
I know,
I know.
I do.
I realize that I got these things,
they work for me.
I'm afraid to venture into other parts of the menu.
You got me.
All right.
So I'd never had Vietnamese food so I was like that.
The whole thing was like,
like what is it?
Like,
what are they going to,
it's always the same shit,
beef,
chicken and pork and just how they dress it up.
So I'm like,
all right.
So I went in there,
I got this chicken sandwich and I saw these shredded carrots on top of that.
I was like,
oh my God,
that's going to be gross.
And I ate it and it was fucking delicious.
So anyways,
but you know,
the chicken was kind of fried.
I told Jade Bat,
oh eight bed and um,
yeah,
so now I got the salt going through my veins and uh,
up the street there was an ice cream place.
So,
so this is all off the rails.
I was in my diet was like,
I'm going to go up to the ice cream place,
so fucking walk in there
and it's one of these new agey ice cream,
uh,
artisan ice cream,
whatever the fuck that means.
All I know is when it says artisan,
if you're an old guy like me,
you're not going to recognize any of the flavor.
Flavor's they had like some,
like I was just looking for chocolate,
vanilla,
strawberry.
The old school shit,
they don't have any of that.
I think I like potato chips in it and shit.
They got one was like chocolate,
a chocolate rose leaf or something.
If anybody can tell me what the fuck that is,
so I just looked at it.
I was just like,
what the fuck is this?
I wasn't there an ice cream store around the corner and when I'll go to that
one,
maybe that's an old school one and I walked into that one.
Same Shit.
They had six flavors.
I couldn't,
I couldn't remember any of them today if you,
if you had a gun to my head.
So I say to the lady,
I just go a eight d,
She got mint chocolate chip.
She goes,
no,
it's not in season.
I was like,
wait,
you mean it's not in season?
And she turns around.
She's like mag waste once mid check,
a chip can be a season in late kids up.
She's like,
I think July.
How fucking ridiculous in season.
Okay.
It's like you're serving ice cream.
This leads to diabetes.
This is poison.
Your body doesn't need this.
There's a lot of studies out there right now that it's saying sugar is a
carcinogen.
You know,
that's just what the fuck you're serving people.
Well,
but it's fresh.
This is in season cancer,
right?
So you know what I did?
I was like,
fuck this.
I just walk out.
I just said,
okay,
thank you.
And I walk out right?
Can you know what I did?
I just went to the same place that old people get their ice cream.
I went to Walgreens,
I went to a pharmacy right now,
all you gotta do is find wherever the photo mat developing places,
and you see about eight old people there with like Insta,
Insta,
fucking cameras,
whatever the hell those things used to be.
And right to the left of it or to the right of it will be ice cream.
And I went there and I walked right in.
I saw Haga does mint chocolate chip.
I bought a whole fucking pint.
I didn't want it.
You know,
I just wanted a small cups.
I bought the whole pint.
That was so fucking tempted to walk back to that ice cream store.
I'd be like,
hey ladies,
it said,
say said,
but I didn't.
And then I went back to the hotel room and even though I was good after reading
like a third of it,
like I didn't have a ref a freezer or anything,
it was going to go bad.
And My mother taught me not to waste.
So I plowed through the whole thing,
ate a pint of ice cream in like the middle of the day.
And my body was just like in,
all right dude,
this is what we're doing.
And I,
I couldn't get out of bed for like the next fucking three hours.
Sugar went through the fucking roof.
My unnatural sugar.
Evidently when,
what,
what season is sugar and what,
see when his sugar in seasons is what I should ask.
Um,
so there you go.
All right.
If you're old and you need ice cream,
you want some ice cream.
At this point I would suggest going to the grocery store or going to a pharmacy
drug store.
They have the old school.
Yeah.
Chocolate,
vanilla,
strawberry,
mint,
chocolate chip,
butter Pecan,
all those old ones.
Okay.
And I don't want to be a fucking asshole old guy,
so I respect the young people in their new crazy flavors,
you know,
where these take other desserts and they stick it in there.
Okay.
You know,
candy bars and brownies and shit.
It's just like,
it's fucking redundant.
Um,
although I will smoke a cigar during some smokey Scotch,
so I dunno.
I Dunno what,
anyways,
I can say that was my,
I uh,
you know,
what's the deal with ice cream?
Soda Story.
Uh,
speaking of ice,
because I become friends with Josh,
Adam mayase,
the host of the goddamn comedy jam.
He's a good friend of mine.
He somehow has me rooting for the fucking Washington capitals,
you know,
every year in the playoffs.
Right.
Obviously if the plane,
my Bruins,
I don't,
okay.
But you know,
so he can,
you know,
feel what it's like to win a championship,
so can put a little sparkle in his eye.
And now he has me watching these,
this fucking team every year.
And I was sitting by myself yesterday.
Yeah.
You know,
if you haven't paid attention to the series,
the lightning,
uh,
lost the first two games.
Capital's one the first two games.
Yeah.
And my buddy was all excited and I said,
hey,
I don't want to be the guide raining on your parade,
but,
uh,
we beat him pretty easily in game one.
And then they,
they just shut us down and ran the fucking table.
So,
uh,
I think I'd wait till I was at least up three games to none before I got excited
about beating the lightning.
Right.
So they won the first two games the capitalists did.
Then the lightning won game three.
They want game four.
And yesterday I'm sitting down watching game five,
um,
watching this adopted team that's going to break your heart every year.
And I was by myself and I literally said to the TV,
you don't have to lightening score to yet another goal.
I just,
I just say he fucking capital's,
it'd be God damn fucking year.
And it was just like,
what am I,
this support and a friend?
And then there's just,
you know,
standing in line for an ass kicking for no goddamn reason itself.
Um,
and how bout those Vegas Nights?
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Making short worth or the Winnipeg jets.
What have they got on that team?
I know they get the flour from Pittsburgh between the pipes.
I guess he's playing fucking unbelievable.
They've got a bunch of old wily veterans coming together.
Yeah,
I dunno.
I,
every time I pictured that team,
it's like,
it's like an over 35 we gain,
you know,
within the NHL,
but a good for that man.
Um,
it's going to be funny.
You know,
the first year they don't make the finals.
How their fans are gonna react to that.
They're going to be so goddamn spoiled in the history of,
of,
of the four major sports.
Has this ever happened?
Has An expansion team in their first year ever?
I could look this up.
Ever made it to like the equivalent of the Superbowl world series type of shit.
Okay.
Has an expansion team
ever made the finals.
Okay.
Then they going to say,
well,
the Vegas Knights did it yesterday.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Vegas become the first expansion team to reach a championship.
Yep.
There you go.
Has an expansion team ever won a championship?
Well,
if no one's ever made the championship game,
that would be a no.
All right.
Is he article expansion teams not supposed to be good,
especially in their first year.
The fact that these clubs have to draft players,
what the fuck was that?
I thought there was a whole sliding off the counter.
Um,
the fact that these clubs was that earthquake just in my kitchen.
The fact that these clubs have to draft players who often aren't important
enough to their current teams to be projected,
although that's not necessarily always the case,
provides expansion teams with a significant disadvantage in their inaugural
seasons season.
This,
however,
the Vegas goal this year,
the Golden Knights have dispelled that notion on their way to a Stanley Cup
final appearance.
Oh,
this is the big thing.
Every year is to Stanley Cup final and it's the NBA finals.
Okay.
It's all how you look at.
If you look at all seven games collectively as the final or if you look at each
game,
this is,
this is an NBA final game.
This is game one of the NBA.
I don't know.
I think the way the hockey does it makes a little more sense.
Um,
how does Vegas stack up against the other expansion teams?
All right,
here we go in the ain't shelled.
The Golden Knights are just a second team since 1952 appear in the final and its
inaugural season joining the St Louis Blues in 1968 that out.
But that's bullshit though.
I'm a,
before I even read the next sentence,
cause I remember,
you know what they did and the NHL.
Okay.
The one from six teams to 12 teams and rather than putting three with the three
original and one conference in three with the three originally,
others,
they have the entire expansion six in their own conference.
So from day one one of them was going to make it there and then get fucking
swept by,
uh,
one of the original six.
Right.
Uh,
what does it say?
However,
the blues were one of six expansion teams that year and all six of them were
placed in the same division,
the winter,
which advanced to the final.
There you go.
Okay.
An mls to Chicago fire shock.
The world world world in 1998 by winning the MLS Cup and US Open Cup in their
first season,
I would say they shot the fucking,
the United States soccer world.
I wouldn't say the shock the world,
but the rest of the world does watch soccer or as they call it,
football.
But I don't think they respect our bullshit right.
By made us look worse.
Right.
But in the major in Major League baseball nor expansion club has finished with
more than 70 wins in its first seasons season in the NBA.
This 1916 Chicago Bulls are the most successful,
successful expansion team.
Jesus Christ.
But only one 33 games.
And in the NFL,
the 1995 Carolina Panthers who finished just seven and nine,
top the list.
Well,
there you go.
There you go,
man.
Um,
after disappointed career at Tampa,
Brett Connolly redeemed himself as a capitol.
It's like there's that next capital game tonight.
Is that what you're telling me?
Yeah,
it's three games to two,
8:00 PM eastern time.
How in the Boston Celtics,
Jesus Christ a series is so fucking long.
They played the first two games and there was like a nine day layoff,
which I think helped all,
uh,
Cleveland.
I would say a bunch of my buddies were all excited.
Like,
dude,
I think the shelter should get a win in fucking five.
They're going to sweep them.
And I'm just like,
uh,
I dunno.
I was just like,
they,
they need to win game three
because if they lose game three,
then it's two to one and then all of a sudden Cleveland can tie it up.
And that's the plastinated thing about a seven game series.
Like if you're three games to one you like,
don't,
we're in the driver's seat the second you lose game five.
Okay.
The rest of the series six and seven,
the pressure's on.
You can,
you can,
can they close them out?
Can they fucking close them out?
So,
uh,
I was joking with a buddy of mine who was a cavalier fan and you say,
you know,
before game three saying,
you guys look great.
And I said,
I won't be comfortable to,
we get that fourth win against you guys.
Um,
uh,
once again you saw what made Lebron fucking so great because he did in that game
what a lot of people with half his skill won't do,
which is past the fucking ball.
And he got all these fucking teammates involved,
um,
in,
anybody can draw that up on paper,
but this guy actually goes out and does it.
And um,
you know,
so now we got the great Brad Stevens.
He's got to figure out a way
to come up with some sort of defensive,
uh,
if that's what Lebron is going to do.
But uh,
this series is far from Ovi the way,
and I'm going to die another thousand deaths tonight.
Watching the Goddamn game
drives me fucking nuts,
man.
It drives me nuts.
Sometimes he ever get like jealous is somebody like as much as like the
Cleveland sports fans,
like the Cleveland browns fans like Bitch Moan and complain
about never winning a Superbowl or anything like that.
It's just like,
you know,
there's no surprise that you're not aging.
Watching them sucky.
Dislike.
Yeah,
they fucking suck.
Blah Blah bloods.
It's over.
It's hopeless.
But if you have a team that makes the playoffs,
they give you hope and you fucking book every,
every time they get to you fucking believe it.
And he'd get all excited.
As much as the Celtics people would say,
you have tremendously overachieved.
If they lose this series,
it's going to be devastating.
And I always get to,
as I've gotten older,
I always just think to myself,
why do I give a shit?
Why do I give you shit like that?
The stuff I have to do when the game is on,
like where I have to go mentally so I could just handle sitting there like I
don't get how people can just fucking sit there and watch it.
I have to go into the other room,
you know,
I've got to start paying bills and stuff while I'm watching the I to have
another activity.
So I'm just not sitting there watching the fucking game,
losing my mind.
Um,
but anyways,
you know,
as much as that we got our asses Hawaii up and gained three,
uh,
you know,
you can't get mad at greatness and that's what I think you saw with the broad.
So who else?
Celtics,
obviously if they went the night,
we'd be up three games to one was yeah,
we shall see what happens.
Um,
and I'm going to watch my,
my surrogate fucking capital's tonight.
We'll see what happens.
Well,
no,
wait,
I'm going to watch the Celtics and I'll be flipping back and forth.
Fucking lightening,
man.
They just give you the old right?
They have it.
What they score is 17 seconds into that game.
Hey,
you go Bam.
Fucking knock a goalie right out of the game before you even get your goddamn
first beer.
They got a bunch of snipers.
Um,
all right,
let me read a little bit of a advertisement
for,
for this week.
Um,
anyways,
but this is my,
this is my last big push here is I s I slide into my fucking 50th birthday here
where,
um,
you know,
I got myself a great shape,
but I think I peaked too early.
Then I had that bad week in San Francisco.
So now we got to have a perfect week just to,
just to get even with what the fuck I did last week and uh,
but I think I'll be all right.
You know,
come in right around one 70 a look.
All right.
You know?
Okay.
At least when I cry when my forties are over and I looked down at my stomach,
it won't be as big and that'll be uplifted.
Does that make sense?
I fucking know.
Right?
Zip Brooke.
Okay.
Uh,
are you hiring,
posting your position to job sites and waiting and waiting for the right people?
See it.
What do you do while you're waiting?
A Zip
knew there was a smarter way.
So they built a platform that finds the right job candidates just for you.
Oh,
zip.
Okay.
Lauren's what you were looking for identifies people with the right experience
and invites them to apply to your job.
These invitations have revolutionize how you find your next hire.
In fact,
80% of employers who post a job on ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate through
the site in just one day.
Uh,
and Ziprecruiter doesn't stop there.
They even spotlight the strongest applications you received,
so you never miss a great match.
A what if somebody lying on their resume,
sorry,
I just didn't want to bring up the fly in the ointment.
The right candidates are out there.
Old Zip
is how you find them.
Businesses of all sizes try zip recruiter for their hiring needs right now.
My listeners can try zip
for free.
That's right.
Free.
Just go to ziprecruiter.com/burr.
That's ziprecruiter.com/bar one more time.
Hi Chip.
Yeah,
the smartest way to hire.
All right,
so anyways,
all freckles.
Oh,
freckles.
Freckles.
Lay it off the fucking booze.
Doo Doo Doo Doo for freckles,
for freckles.
I'm actually seriously considering getting rid of my bar.
Can you put like half drank?
Fuck is that
sounds like the beginning of like a movie ripping off a said Eddie Murphy Movie
Axel Foley.
But do boom,
boom,
boom.
What do you think was playing other than the original porn?
It's actually a highlight for the Vegas Knights.
Vegas will be the play the winner of the capital series.
Okay,
so that's on the sports illustrated if you'd like to have that as a ring,
but do Doodoo boop,
boop.
Um,
let's see what this one sounds like.
Oh,
this is the old guy chasing a woman to the train.
I saw this woman,
she was beautiful.
She was beautiful.
I had to talk to her.
Well,
you could do that and fucking real life.
See some woman on a platform and then start running towards her train.
You know,
how do you not come off as a creep peaky Gig?
You can't even be walking briskly.
I would think of that alone would freak a woman up.
Like,
what the fuck is this guy doing it?
You don't ever want a stranger walking briskly towards you.
Um,
anyways,
that,
I mean,
that's just my opinion.
It's just my opinion.
People.
That's all this fucking podcast is.
It's just my opinion over and over and over again for 60 God damn minutes.
And you just got to sit there and take it.
Oh,
you shut it off.
You know,
that's always an option.
You could do that instead of sitting there playing the victim,
you know,
and writing a blog about it.
I was so mentally abused by the Monday morning podcast,
I couldn't reach up and hit stop.
MMM.
All right.
So I've been downloading a bunch of fucking,
like late seventies and early eighties as such.
Talk a music here.
Um,
I was watching something,
uh,
what's his face there?
That the lead singer of he was in black fat flag.
Oops.
Jesus Christ didn't need to say that
black flag.
The fuck is his name.
Um,
he had a band.
He had a band named after him.
Oh Jesus Christ in my brain is so fucking fried.
I keep thinking Bronson like Mark Ronson.
I know it's not that,
but the fuck is this guy,
Dan.
All right.
And I could look this shit up.
Don't fucking laugh at me cause I know,
I know.
I'm not the only one who does this shit.
Black flag lead singer.
This is why I can never be on jeopardy because even though when I know the
fucking answers,
okay,
he won't,
I know the God damn answers Henry Rollins,
Jesus fucking Christ.
So I saw this thing,
Henry Rollins,
right?
And he was recommending these albums.
Some of them I had,
some of them I didn't.
And uh,
so he recommended this band joy division and it's like,
all right,
I've heard of this band for fucking ever.
I never took the time to get into them or any of that shit.
If this guy is saying this is the real shit.
Um,
and he was saying their original album is as good as anything the rolling stones
ever did and blah,
blah,
blah.
So I went out how in a right to iTunes and promptly downloaded their second
album by accident.
I got to tell you,
I love it.
So I'm gonna,
I'm gonna go back kind of
fucked up because I should have done it chronologically and seen the growth even
though they went around that long.
Cause,
unfortunately,
the lead singer committed suicide,
uh,
barely 24 years old,
but Jesus Christ,
there was some fucking unbelievable bands that came out of Manchester in,
uh,
the late seventies and early eighties.
That was so god damn different from everything else that was going on.
Considering that first album that I haven't listened to yet,
if it sounds anything like the second album,
which came out in [inaudible] 79 to listen to that music and know that like
popular music was like at the time was like,
I love that.
I got to a bull gay honor this girl.
Right.
Yay.
I won't to pull down my,
my,
my boogie shoes.
Ban It and know,
hey fucking lady,
let's go create some herpes.
Bane.
That's what all the sons were.
We're going to stop fucking until you can die from this shit.
Go to bed.
Um,
Carmona now coco cocaine's not addictive brain.
All right,
sorry.
Um,
anyways,
but you know what's so funny,
I liked disco music too.
I like to shit because I was too young to know that it evidently everybody
fucking hated it.
And when I hear that Shit,
you know,
a Buddha pit bull,
that bull with it.
Just,
just Paul,
you get it.
No,
I just pictured myself riding my bicycle up to the store to buy some football
cards or baseball cards.
All right.
I didn't know any better.
I didn't realize that that was the music of
man,
man.
I had no idea.
Wow.
See,
hey,
I taught all of that shit was like a thought that was legit.
No idea.
Anyways,
check out joy division.
Download their first album,
like can be wrong and said,
don't fucking accidentally downloads the second one and then defend disco like I
just did on my podcast.
Okay.
You don't have to.
So I was listening to that and then I was listening to,
uh,
that led me to remember Romeo void.
Never say never.
I never knew what the woman,
uh,
look like or anybody in the band.
One of the coolest looking at bench,
you're ever going to see it now once again,
way ahead of their fucking time
video for never say never.
It's cool.
It's like a fucking movie.
And I,
I know I used to watch MTV all the time.
I barely remember them ever play in this.
Uh,
but I would say Romeo void and a joy division,
both of them,
me listening to them really sitting down listening to that shit for the first
time in 2018.
And the music still holds up.
It doesn't feel like,
you know,
uh,
what are some of the popular shit?
I'll fight Dowell.
Dad
Won't go to a junk car.
That's not a bad song either.
Right.
I,
you know,
something you can't,
you can't objectively look at any music that was out when you were growing up.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
Because there was like,
Oh man,
I'm in with his song came on.
That's the,
uh,
first time I got,
yeah.
Hung on a door,
not by my underwear,
by the [inaudible].
You got all these skew,
all these great childhood fucking memories.
I remember that,
that set time,
that fucking
teacher locked me in the closet because he had to go do something.
He didn't have time to like fucking,
you know,
watch me during detention.
Yeah.
I remember that.
I remember that day.
That was a day that fucking,
I don't want to get knowledge all that shit anyways,
check them out if you get a chance.
I guess that was the point of all that.
The point of all that
was to check the,
check those people up if he,
if,
if you have,
if you have time,
um,
if you don't,
I understand.
Just keep listening to the shit you listen to.
You know,
I kind of noticed that when,
uh,
when I went to that giant Bob Baseball game last week,
like there was a couple of guys that came to the plate and they would just
listen to this,
remember that new metal in some of that horrific shit that came out in the early
two thousands,
you know,
when they tried to combine wrap and metal,
and it's,
everybody would be up there playing instruments and then that'd be that one
white kid running around.
You're like,
Oh God,
is he going to start rapping?
Please God,
don't,
don't let them start rapping.
That is the one amazing thing about that style of music.
That was the one style of music that white people,
as much as they tried,
just could not steal it,
you know,
not say that day.
You know,
Evan and some guys like that.
I haven't been tremendous,
but you know,
that is one.
It was just,
I don't know what it was.
He just,
white people did best bet,
man.
That was that whole Jen and the music was so good that that white kids got into
it and then they did,
hey man,
we ought to put that in our band,
but at that,
but a yo just didn't work.
It just didn't work.
Um,
there was a lot of stuff from that time that just fucking didn't work.
I remember she slam poetry.
Oh my God,
Jesus Christ.
That was just like,
I just remembered the person who would ever be doing it would always have their
eyebrows up and be like,
pointing at you.
Like what they were saying was just fucking unbelievable.
It's just unbelievable.
And it was like blowing your mind.
Yeah.
And I would just be sitting there going like that.
You know,
that's kind of a very uh,
mainstream point of view that has been
said about people in power for a long time.
I guess I've never heard it rhymed before.
So that makes it,
no,
I don't know.
But I could look at it objectively because that was yet another time to stand
up.
Comedians would go on like,
oh my God,
did she go to take all the standup comedy?
We're all good at be fucking homeless.
Right.
I told you guys about that time when in Massachusetts anyway.
So do you remember he karaoke?
They still have karaoke,
right?
Which I know a lot of bands hold nervous that that was going to end.
People are going to see live music,
you know,
cause some plumber who was going to be standing on stage go on
Libby.
Um,
white people at that point,
would it be like,
you know,
I don't think I need to see this generation's Freddie mercury cause I could
watch the guy just plumbed my fucking toilet sink journey.
Think I'm all set on professional musicians at this point.
Thank you.
Karaoke,
but you know
how it is GP,
you're live in fear.
It's what it is.
People live in fear.
So anyways,
um,
the,
uh,
there was something that came out was called carry jokey and basically people in
the restaurant or whatever would go on stage and that'd be a teleprompter and
they would just read a joke like,
you know,
two guys walk into a bar and the bartender says double double day for Blah,
blah,
blah blah blah.
Hey,
I didn't know that.
I would have fucking yelling at,
at an hour ago.
And then they couldn't teach timing.
Right.
But we were all convinced like Duke carry jokey,
it's h it's going to do to stand up comedy.
What Karaoke did to live music,
which was absolutely nothing unless you were in an incredibly shitty band.
Um,
so one time we were,
uh,
I know I've told this story before,
this is for the new listeners.
Alright.
So one time I was doing this gig somewhere in New Hampshire was upstairs at a
bar,
the two story bar.
Okay.
People take drinking seriously in New England to story fucking Bar,
you know,
and there was plenty of room to add on to the bar.
It wasn't like,
you know,
it was this densely populated area.
Um,
I don't know.
This guy was just building up for whatever reason.
So we're on the second story of this fucking building and across the street is
this little carnival
and a,
all I remember was you know that,
you know that Viking ship ride you again,
it just basically it's like a giant swing going back and forth,
but you're on that giant boat.
So uh,
that is basically right outside the windows on the second floor of this bar.
And there was screened windows too,
cause it was the summer and I guess this place must not have had air
conditioning.
And all I remember was standing on stage bombing and all I could hear was people
screaming on the ride.
So my set,
it turned into like my own little horror film.
And what was funny was the boat was not like parallel to the bar.
It was like pointed at it and it looked like it was going to come right through
the fucking window and then it would go up.
I remember the guy I was looking at was saying,
you know,
it's very phallic looking right.
And I was dying laughing because when the underneath the boat was coming up and
go back,
it looked like,
you know,
that ridiculous shot and porno.
We're just in case you'd think he's really not putting it in there.
They make good and God damn well you know that that's what's happening.
Um,
I always wonder if like the porn star can feel the heat of the Lens,
unlike the ball bags and fucking who has,
you know,
maybe that's why they shave their pubes because they got sick of him lighting on
fire during takes.
I don't know.
I've never really seen him behind this.
Actually.
I did see a behind the scenes of a porno recently of a performer,
porn star of this guy getting into the world and then wanting to get out of it
and staying in it
for 20 fucking years.
And,
uh,
I watched the whole thing right up until when he decided to get out of it.
And then the next one was him in Bible study and a,
then I shut it off.
You know,
I was just like,
all right,
I don't want to watch this part.
You know,
reminding me that I'm a piece of shit and I should probably look at Bible study
in her something.
I don't know what the fuck it is.
They said something,
oh,
he's wigs me out about that.
Um,
you know what I mean?
Cause he can sit Tivoli,
hey man,
like that stuff doesn't exist man.
You also thinking,
well,
what does this,
what does exist?
These are the ramblings of a guide turned 50 going like,
do,
do I need to hedge my bets and start going back to church?
But when the higher power,
no,
like this guy not totally buying into this shit.
What is he doing right now?
Is he practicing some sort of sticking pattern on the church pews?
40 plays drums later on today.
That's not very respectful.
Um,
all right,
let's,
let's do some reads here for this week.
Uh,
grass fed versus grass finished.
dear Billy beef breath releasing on your podcasts,
you did an ad for your new sponsor butcher box.
By the way,
I uh,
I tried that,
that pork that they stet swag that they sent me and it was a,
you know,
I didn't realize like the original pigs that came over here before,
I guess they were all mixed with these other pigs.
It's very like white supremacy the way they have like the pigs and dogs,
like pure bred and all that.
Well these pure bred pigs like you gotta you gotta prove that their DNA that
these are actually,
you know,
I don't know what takes from fucking Liverpool.
I have no idea.
All I can tell is that,
you know,
I bought into the hype so I don't know if that affected my taste buds,
but it was one of the best pork chops I've ever had in my life.
So hats off to butcher box.
Anyways,
he said you didn't know what the term grass finished beef meats.
It means they are giving you the real thing.
A lot of restaurants.
These,
they tell you they serve grass fed beef and they usually charge more for it.
The term used to mean exactly what it sounds like,
but it's all gotten watered down now
down and now it's often just a marketing gimmick.
Pretty much all cattle are grass fed.
They are fed grass pellets.
Hey.
Or if they are lucky they get to spend their lives happily grazing in a pasture.
But then all of us,
almost all of them get fed grain or other garbage to fatten them up at the feed
lot before slaughter grasp finished,
however means they eat grass right up until the very end.
I learned this little bit of Trivia when I was working as a travel writer in
Hawaii.
I want it to pass it along because I figure I owe you.
That's pretty cool.
Uh,
I started,
let's do a podcast and Joe Rogan's podcast because I frequently had long drives
by myself to get to remote areas of the various islands and persons can only
listen to so much and a person can only listen to so much Hawaiian music.
That's hilarious.
Uh,
thanks for keeping me company long drives.
No problem.
In case you've never been to Hawaii before and are questioning my comment about
long drives.
The Big island is about the size of the state of Connecticut.
I didn't know that and said Sarah,
no direct routes.
It takes more than two hours to get from the Kona side of the big island to the
high low side where the volcano is currently erupting.
You know,
the bright side of that volcano erupting is,
isn't it?
Creating more land,
you know?
Well,
you know,
fitting out the population of an Emily.
Uh,
here's the link about the term grass fed so you can verify for yourself,
but it's a long article.
So probably not something you want to read on the podcast.
Dude.
If it's a short article,
it's not something,
one of my read on the podcast,
God knows I fucked that up.
How scary is it to not only live next to a fucking volcano,
but to be like on a Goddamn island?
I mean,
I don't,
the only thing that I've,
I've seen that has been not,
not like a little more relaxing is how slow lava the lava has been moving.
You know,
after it's sort of a rub sweat,
he's still to be near it will,
you know,
spitting up like a fucking toddler.
Right.
Um,
okay.
Let me see.
Let me read up on this shit.
Hawaii volcano.
What is the latest why ball cane?
A warning of toxic gas plumes,
a lava spews lays of toxic gas and glass into the air.
This spewing glass.
Did people throw their fucking soda pop bottles down there or is that some
chemically way that all of those minerals with that level of heat turns into
glass,
lava acid rain vog sulfur dioxide and now lays new deadly thread emerges.
Good fucking Lord.
Can you imagine if you're there right now on your honeymoon?
You can't tell me that's not an almond.
Did I marry the right person?
God,
give me a sign.
That could mean,
you know,
okay,
actually maybe a good thing,
right?
Put the eruption.
You know it's going to fuck your brains out.
I don't,
I don't pretend to know.
Okay.
First it was lava,
then acid,
rain and fog.
What the fuck is Vog I so far behind the stories,
people know what Vog is.
Fog
vog is a form of air pollution.
Yeah.
That results when sulfur dioxide and other gases and particles emitted by
interrupting volcano react with the oxygen and moisture in the presence of
sunlight.
The word is a poor Manto Portmanteau port man to have the word volcanic smog in
fog.
You mean the smoke that comes out of a volcano?
They call it vog.
The term is common in the Hawaiian islands.
Okay.
All right.
Fog is created when volcanic gases react with sunlight,
oxygen,
and moisture.
The results includes sulfur,
sulfuric acid,
and other self.
Jesus fucking Christ
as poor people.
Yeah.
Live in that Goddamn Paradise.
Just sitting there,
you know,
so like school gets canceled out there.
There will be no school today due to the vog.
We got to go an extra two weeks and Joe,
because we missed those two weeks,
you know,
three months earlier when the volcano was erupting.
I can a wide people at tough,
Huh?
Oh did we get a little snow storm?
It's gotta be slippery.
Okay.
You could slip and fall and break your tailbone.
Yeah.
Then on the other side,
that's,
and they go,
oh,
really?
Now we could burn to death.
Be vaporized.
Right?
You go outside and breathe and poisoned.
So what the fuck?
What does everybody do it not like how poisoned it says it.
Jesus Christ.
Can you imagine that shit like you still decide to go ahead with your vacation
and as you're coming in for a landing,
you seen all that fog.
Okay,
honey,
it's okay.
Stop crying.
We're,
we're on the other side of the island.
Okay.
It's just a honey.
It's just lover.
Okay.
It's just lava and a little bit of poison gas and,
and it's,
it's currently still happening.
Other than that,
I mean,
it's going to be fine.
You can be sitting on the beach with,
with,
with a lei around your neck and a gas mask on your face,
taking a big gulp of oxygen before you lift the mask and take a sip off you
straw drinking out of a coconut just like we plant.
Come on.
This is our time.
Okay,
come on.
We're going to start a family.
Um,
oh fingers.
I couldn't find my shoes.
Okay.
Don't rock day.
I just wanted to go home,
ma.
Um,
alright.
Hey,
stay strong.
Hawaii.
I Dunno.
What else should dope?
I would sell.
Well,
yeah know if you're near the ocean.
The lava comes.
You just fucking,
just stand in the ocean.
Okay.
Then the sharks come and get you,
right.
I mean,
there's just no way to fucking do it.
How do we literally stare to the Osha?
I be like,
I mean like fucking,
you know,
stand along the beach.
Frolic in the waves.
As you watch your retirement fund in your house burned up in flames.
Did anybody else see that footage of that lava?
Just kind of going across the street right towards that white car?
Did it bug you that nobody's a key?
She'd get the fucking car out of there.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
I'll tell you right now,
if you ever steal a car and you want to get rid of it,
that's it.
Steal a car.
Well,
a volcano is erupting.
Have you a little joy ride,
right?
The cops chased you.
Just drive it into some lava and then you fucking jump out.
So what man,
I don't see any car.
And then you know would happen was they would have the dashboard cam and then
they'd get you for fucking,
I don't know,
destroying evidence.
I don't know what the fuck it,
why,
who knows?
I don't pretend to understand things.
All right.
Improve Your Franch.
Dear Billy Bilingual,
I'm a 24 year old American man who completed a year abroad in Paris.
I knew no French before going and now I'm now flowing.
Yeah,
well that's the way to do it.
You're over there.
I know you've been using Rosetta stone and that's really helpful.
But here's a tip on how you can become conversationally fluid flowing.
Oh Great.
The best thing to do is listen to the audio book and read this text
simultaneously in French.
I know you hate reading,
but if you get a good narrator,
it can be entertaining.
It will make you literate.
Oh yeah.
I've been reading,
I've been reading French books,
like kids' books to my daughter.
Um,
I read Harry Potter and
Lick Cole Dis
saucer is whatever,
and I was able to chat up French women afterwards.
Hope this helps and go fuck yourself.
Well,
wait a minute.
If someone's just speaking French and nobody's translating it for me.
Yeah,
I'm just listening to French.
Okay.
How does it work?
Um,
audio book
and read the texts simultaneously.
Let me see something.
French audio book
with Avec text.
Let's see what I got here.
French parallel audio.
Oh,
we're going to,
you know what?
I'm going to do it.
I'll give it a shot.
Thank you very much.
All Jesus.
Look at this one.
Oh Gee.
She is a police.
Caught me with the prostitute.
What's up bill?
A big fan of yours.
I enjoy your all.
I enjoy your,
all your standups.
Okay.
I'm gonna say this is this first draft.
Your Netflix originals especially F is for family.
Thank you.
And your interviews on youtube.
Mostly the ones on Conan.
I'm 28 years old.
Single.
No kids live alone.
Kind of a loner.
I smoke weed.
I work midnight at a gas station.
All right,
let's do this again.
28 years old,
single,
no kids.
I live alone.
Kind of a loner.
I smoke weed.
I work midnight at a gas station.
I never go out.
I don't drink.
I don't do any kind of clubs are hardcore drugs.
I just get horny.
I usually have girls,
but not this time.
Uh,
I fucked it up with every girl I was talking to.
Somehow I managed to be rude by asking them if they enjoy giving head.
Oh boy.
Uh,
I got to say,
man,
I got caught up in some bullshit tomorrow.
I have a trial and I'm a little nervous.
I have to get it.
A court appointed attorney.
I don't trust anyone though.
The lawyer I was supposed to have would stop asking me for money when I told her
I have it in three days.
I don't lie.
I'm honest as fuck.
All right.
I always get nervous when people say,
I don't lie,
have you?
But anybody knows me,
knows I tell the truth.
I didn't do that.
All right.
So basically what happened,
I got pulled over by the cops telling me straight up.
Uh,
they saw me talking with a known prostitute for sure.
It was a sting operation,
even though she showed me her tits.
She was cute.
Too Cute.
If you ask me a little too cute.
Um,
so she got in my car and asked me what I wanted.
I told her,
but she wanted more money,
so I said,
no thanks.
Uh,
she got out and I decided to go home.
I pull out into the street and literally not even 30 seconds later,
I see lights come on behind me.
Luckily I didn't go to jail.
They gave me a ticket and impounded my car though.
All right.
So what's the problem?
I've been bullshit.
My mom,
I told her the car's in the shop.
I thought you said you don't lie and that you're honest is fuck.
Anyways,
I had to spend two grand to get it back,
but it was in my mom's name,
so I had to come up with another lie.
I thought you said you didn't lie.
Give honest says fuck.
And I was trying to sell the car even though that makes no fucking sense.
What?
So I needed paperwork stating she was my mother giving me permission to retrieve
my car from the county clerk's office and have it notarized by the bank.
I know,
Bill,
I don't lie.
If I told my mom she this,
she probably die.
All right,
so we kind of covered his tracks and no joke.
I'm the youngest of five all fuck ups.
All boys.
I'm supposed to be the good one and am I was just being stupid.
I think the only thing that's worrying me is the phone.
Probably like five to 10 grand.
Oh,
well thanks for the time to read this by the way.
I live.
I'm like,
see,
we live.
I have tickets to your show.
Uh,
can't wait anyways,
thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
All right,
well she's probably going to find out.
I would just tell her,
I just tell him to say,
listen,
I fucked up.
You know,
Uh,
she's your mother.
She'll forgive you,
right?
I Dunno.
I think I would be more worried about the five to $10,000.
Fine.
Then your mom not loving you anymore.
All right.
You fucked up.
You made a mistake.
Everybody makes mistakes.
I make mistakes.
You'll,
you made a mistake.
Um,
you know,
it's with the fucking life is you make mistakes.
You learn from your mistakes,
you move on,
you try to do better.
All right.
That's it.
I've said it for a long time.
If people were cars,
we'd be recalled.
There's a reason the world is so fucked up.
It's because humans are running it.
Okay?
We just smart enough to be fucking morons.
Um,
all right.
Good luck to you.
My friend's dad wants to pay me to get naked.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Okay.
Well the last one,
girlfriend and best friends graduating.
Same time,
different places.
Thank you.
A nice sit,
calm trope.
I can finish with here.
I got two dates in one night.
All right,
let's get through this one.
Mike Day.
My friend's dad wants to pay me to get naked.
Oh,
Jesus.
A Mr. William Frederick [inaudible].
Hope you're doing good.
Big Fan of the podcast and all your other shit.
Keep doing what you're doing.
I'm a 24 year old guy from the UK.
Okay.
The UK until recently I've been working behind the bar in the local pub where my
friend's dad would drink regularly.
I'd met him I handful of times over the past 10 years or so as his son,
as his son is one of my best friends.
He's about 70 years old and a very devout Catholic.
Oh,
that's not a good characteristic.
Who has also worked at the church in some other capacity or another?
I shouldn't blame the whole religion.
Okay.
Because maybe he's a good guy.
All right.
I've always got a weird vibe from him.
I'll boy,
and he started to see me even with her out Jesus.
After seeing him multiple times in a week,
he was giving me big tips,
which is rare in the UK,
and he would cut my hand with both hands for 10 seconds or so.
When he gave them money to me,
he'd stare into my eyes saying all this weird complimentary stuff about me.
Like,
you're a very good bar man,
and you'll go far.
Sorry.
The bad accent.
So I started to feel something was off about this guy.
Yeah.
God.
This is like when quint slit into the mouth of the shark,
a one day after a month,
a few months of generous tips from him and general weird encounters.
He had about five large glasses of red wine and got pretty drunk.
As I was walking around the pub collecting glasses,
he called me over to him and pulled me to one side and a dark dimly lit corner.
He hushed his voice,
ah,
and got really close to me with his putrid breath wafting into my nose and said
something along the lines of,
right.
I have a proposition for you.
First off,
I just want to make it clear that I'm not gay.
Oh,
Jesus.
I'm not gay at all.
Right.
Um,
well,
I want to do,
but I do have,
what I do have is an appreciation of for the male form,
I can't keep doing this accident when I do have is an appreciation for the male
form.
I used to have a boy who I would pay 150 pounds,
which is 200 euros.
That's our 203 American really
to allow me to look at his body a few times per week.
I wouldn't touch him or force him to do anything.
He would simply get undressed and I would appreciate his body and pay him for
it.
Time to sit.
Sound like something you would be interested in?
Oh my God.
I immediately said no.
He was pretty shocked,
but I didn't make a scene.
I just laughed it off and said,
sorry,
I'm not interested.
The next day he came into the pub and practically begged me not to tell his son
and started to give me even
okay.
Fingertips in the following weeks.
I tried to refuse,
but he insisted it was basically hush money.
It was like I was wrapped up in some sort of big scandal and being paid for my
silence.
Okay.
Um,
there was one time where he ran into the pub looking really flustered during a
storm.
What little hair he has left was all over the place and we stuck to his,
to his red,
wet veiny face,
Jesus Christ.
His clothes were drenched.
He was really out of breath and he ran up to me and said,
you haven't told him,
have you?
That's fucking nuts.
Because the person was probably acting weird or slightly different.
I haven't told him no.
I said he was clearly really worried about what he'd said,
so I couldn't help but feel a little sorry for him as he's clearly gay and most
likely suppressed it his entire life to Dan being a devout Catholic.
That's what I was thinking.
I feel bad for that.
I felt,
you know,
obviously that you had to fucking have that fucking interaction.
But I mean,
yeah,
that's what this is.
This is why you should just let people be who the fuck they are.
Uh,
my gut instinct is to just never mention it to anyone.
But a second opinion would be great.
Yeah.
Do it.
I wouldn't say it's these 70 fucking years old.
All right.
You know,
to his credit,
he asked you,
said no,
and then that was it.
And now he's just saying,
please don't tell anybody.
Anyway,
so essentially I know that one of my best friend's dad is trying to cheat on his
mom with young men.
So part of me feels like his wife has the right to know,
but on the other hand,
I don't want to ruin their family.
So my question to you is,
should I bring it up with my friend?
What should I do?
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
Uh,
but instead just have a nice thanks a dog.
Go Fuck Yourself.
One said,
just have a nice day for me.
Will you?
Um,
all right.
Uh,
sending loud to yourself,
knee and the little baby.
Thank you.
Looking forward to the new efs family.
Ah,
not the case.
Fucking seven years old.
I mean,
uh,
what are you going to do at that point?
You know,
I don't,
I don't know as the Guy Bisexual,
I have no fucking idea.
Okay.
All I know is he asked,
you said no and he's left you alone other than panicking that you're going to
fucking tell somebody.
So,
uh,
I feel like his,
okay.
If he wants to tell people that's his,
that's his thing.
You know what I mean?
I don't fucking know
fall.
Yeah.
I mean,
I would think that his wife on some level might even fucking know who the fuck
that relationships are very complex to just fucking jump in there and think that
you're going to be playing the hero when you don't have any of the information.
I would just just walk away from it.
Yeah.
Just walk away.
That's what I would do personally.
You know?
Uh,
Jesus Christ.
What a story I felt.
I was watching a movie.
All right.
Girlfriend and best friend graduating.
Same time,
different places.
Dear Billy,
bombshell by breast friend in new girlfriend or graduating college on the same
day and I don't know who's ceremony to attend.
I just finished my junior year,
uh,
of college and recently started dating a girl one year older who is graduating
in less than a week.
However,
my best friends since I was five,
also graduating college on the same day at the same time,
but at a different school.
Needless to say,
I cannot be at both places at once.
I'm not really sure who ceremony I should attend.
I don't want to piss off my new girlfriend,
especially because she's way too hot for me.
Um,
well she's way too hard for you.
That's a good thing to try to like keep yourself level is don't fucking jump
every time she asks you to.
MMM.
I,
I would go to my buddy's graduation to say,
unfortunately,
you know
it,
they just
came at the same time.
You know what's funny is a one would be like,
can you a good issue.
Like,
and I would never do that if I was dating a girl for a year.
And she's like,
listen,
your graduation is the same day as my best friend since sounds five before she
got through it,
I died.
Listen,
I get it.
No fucking problem.
Hey,
here's a little secret.
I don't want to go to the graduation ceremony myself.
I just got to get the peace of God damn paper.
That's the only reason why I'm showing up.
Don't worry.
I'll take a video.
All right.
It gives a fuck.
It's just,
it's a ceremony.
MMM.
He says his name.
We're really unsure.
I can justify picking a new girlfriend over my best friend,
but at the same time he doesn't give me sex.
So there's that aspect.
Let me know what I think should do.
I don't think you should operate from a place of fear.
I think you should go with loyalty and you should go to your friend's thing.
That's what I would do.
You know,
if she can't understand it,
uh,
what are you going to do?
Plenty of fish in the sea.
All right.
False rape allegations.
Ruining my friend's life.
Jesus fucking Christ.
I hate reading these things cause I don't have any of the information.
Now you gonna tell me it's a false rape.
Thanks.
So now I don't know if I'm actually,
I'm going to be supporting a victim or if I'm going to be fucking,
uh,
supporting somebody who really did something.
Here's the situation.
I'm curling my senior year of college,
my graduate,
I did,
I'm not reading this fucking thing.
Look at the psycho bitch got mad at Blah Blah.
Now,
this is all like,
this is what's wrong with the Internet right now is because now I'm going to
listen to one side of the fucking story.
The woman who you call a psycho bitch is not going to get a chance to tell her
side of the story and I'm going to make a snap judgment and say,
yeah,
you know,
this is a psycho bitch.
I just,
you know,
I like,
these are like the question.
Choose to be a lot lighter people.
This is some heavy fucking shit.
My Dad's,
my best friend's dad is 70 and I found out he's gay.
Should I tell them or should I keep this secret?
What the way?
At what point did I become qualified to answer this shit?
I don't fucking know.
Yeah.
Anyways,
that's the podcast.
Yeah,
go Celtics.
Go capital's a and go fuck yourself.
I'll talk to you on Thursday.
I'll check in on you.